c'est l'heure de la reprise pour les
seconds dans ce lycée polyvalent
d'achères après trois modes cours à la
maison
les élèves sont de retour physiquement
dans l'établissement ce vendredi 12 juin
qu'un peu parce qu on est plus habitués
à travailler dans un endroit et scolaire
parce qu'on travaille à la maison mais
après c'est cool de revoir ses camarades
des classes et de retrouver un peu une
ambiance conviviale des travail ici la
classe / 4 pour s'adapter à la crise
sanitaire
les groupes sont composés de 9 élèves au
contact ça change pas grand chose mais
en fait ce qui change pour nous les
professeurs c'est qu'on doit maintenir
un travail à distance pour toute la
partie de la classe qui n'est pas là et
en même temps faire le travail en classe
donc un petit peu plus un petit peu plus
au travail par rapport à la normale
autre changement les 800 élèves de
l'établissement doivent également
pratiqué les gestes barrière dans
l'ensemble de la structure
le port du masque est désormais présent
au lycée dès qu'on rentre le gel
hydroalcoolique et l'ensemble des gestes
barrières
ce qui nous a amenés à entraîner une
gestion des flux notamment dans des
couloirs et dans les salles de classe la
rectrice de l'académie de versailles
charline avenel est venu ce jour là pour
voir l'application de ces mesures dans
cet établissement les élèves ont besoin
d'abord de sociabilité entre eux ils ont
besoin de retrouver leurs professeurs
ils ont besoin de faire le point sur
leur apprentissage ils ont besoin d
conforté ils ont besoin de préparer la
rentrée
et cette reprise est absolument crucial
les élèves continueront sur ce format
jusqu'au 3 juillet au minimum date de la
fin des cours